[Music]
the person who got perhaps the most hate
in the split it wasn't Chris it wasn't
on up but Jennifer Lawrence I mean
Twitter blew off with people blaming her
for the breakup how about this one
quotes this is all Jennifer Lawrence's
fault and watch Chris Pratt and Jennifer
Lawrence be a thing here's the thing
people J law actually has a man and now
for the first time she's talking all
about him I would be so bad at getting
interrogated I would just look
immediately guilty anyway um what kind
of hard-hitting journalistic questions
the topic is Jay laws almost one year
relationship with her director boyfriend
Darren Aronofsky she's 26 he's 48 Jay
law says simply we had energy but
quickly adds I had energy for him I
don't know how he felt about me speaking
openly for her new Vogue cover story
Jennifer describes Darren as brilliant
and an amazing father he has a son from
his previous relationship with the mummy
star Rachel vice here happy the couple
started dating after filming wrapped on
their movie mother
j-law went to a darker place for the
role in fact shooting got so intense
jennifer hyperventilated and dislocated
a rib she says i have oxygen tubes in my
nostrils and Darrin's like it was out of
focus we've got to do it again and I was
just like go bleep yourself oh yeah
that's the kind of relationship these
two have oh and the Harvard grad does
not get Jayla's obsession with reality
TV like the Real Housewives and the
Kardashians she laughs he just finds it
so vastly disappointing no talking I can
hear you thinking
aside from talking about her man and
looking glam at her fashion shoot j-law
drops this little challenge I used to
talk to horses because I didn't
France and I know I miss meeting with
that stuff I don't want to talk about it
anymore whatever you're funny
so we all talked to horses sometimes I
voice whisper yeah
[Music]
you